Movie trailers in general are often guilty
of lying to us, and it seems that goes double
for Star Wars.
The Rise of Skywalker trailers have made us
believe we're going to see a number of things
that probably won't happen, here's a look
at some of the biggest misdirects.
One of the most surprising shots in the Rise
of Skywalker marketing comes from the second
trailer, which was released at the D23 Expo
in August.
We're talking about the shot of Rey in a hooded
cloak, holding a lightsaber with two red beams.
We've never seen a lightsaber like that in
a Star Wars movie, so it's an intriguing reveal
on its own, but then it unfolds into a double-ended
weapon reminiscent of Darth Maul's.
Clearly, this shot is meant to make you wonder
if Rey will follow up on her Dark Side temptations
and go evil for the end of the trilogy.
But no one really thinks that's going to happen,
right?
Especially after the marketing team for The
Last Jedi did…kind of the exact same thing
already.
"I don't believe that."
A couple explanations come to mind.
The first is that Rey is having a dream or
vision, like Luke did during his visit to
Dagobah in The Empire Strikes Back.
Another possibility is that the dark version
of Rey is some kind of evil clone.
We don't know for sure, but it seems the least
likely option is that this shining beacon
of hope will turn evil and stay that way in
the final installment of her trilogy.
"It's not true."
Also seen in the second Rise of Skywalker
trailer is a brief but curious shot of everyone's
trusty and perpetually anxious protocol droid,
C-3PO, with conspicuously red eyes.
The big implication here is that somehow C-3PO
has been tampered with in some way.
The droid's red eyes are a first in his Skywalker
saga arc and they seem to imply that some
entity has infiltrated C-3PO.
Why else would they go red?
"I'm so confused."
C-3PO's red eyes seem like a misdirect, intended
to mislead viewers by encouraging them to
think that the droid has turned to the dark
side.
Is it a temporary malfunction?
Maybe a simple problem with some faulty wiring?
Our favorite golden droid isn't getting any
younger, so it's not surprising that he might
need a tune-up or upgrade 40 years on.
But the red eyes somehow indicating C-3PO
is going to become a tool for the dark side
is probably one idea we should definitely
drop.
The final trailer for The Rise of Skywalker
features a shot of Rey and Kylo Ren fighting
side by side.
Considering that plenty of other footage shows
them fighting each other, it's tough to gauge
what The Rise of Skywalker wants us to believe
about these characters.
We've already seen Rey and Kylo Ren work together
to defeat Snoke and his guards in The Last
Jedi.
They've also shared a connection through their
Force sensitivities, even communicating and
tracking one another's movements.
It would be easy to think the Skywalker saga
was gearing up to make some grandiose statement
about finding and embracing the gray area
between the light and dark sides of the Force
and teaming up with your presumed enemy against
a far bigger threat.
On the other hand, Rey and Kylo Ren returned
to their respective "teams" after defeating
Snoke in The Last Jedi and remained enemies
through the end of the film.
By showing us scenes of them fighting against
and alongside each other, it's clear they
don't want us to know what actually happens.
The big question that comes from the shot
of Rey and Kylo Ren teaming up in the trailer
is why they're doing it in the first place.
Is there a mutual recognition of their power
and capabilities?
Are they really teaming up, or just trying
to exploit each other?
To keep all that a mystery, the marketing
is trying to have it both ways.
Rey's backstory has been a mystery for Star
Wars fans ever since Episode Seven first came
out, years ago.
She's essentially the main character of Star
Wars right now, and we really don't know a
lot about her, past or present, other than
the fact that she's really, really good at
using the Force.
Very few clues have been dropped about her
life before we meet her in The Force Awakens.
To date, all we know is that she was abandoned
on the planet Jakku, which led her to a life
of scavenging, believing she was nobody.
Through interrogations and tense conversations,
Kylo Ren has frequently hinted that he knows
the truth about Rey's past, including her
parents, who were apparently no one special,
"filthy junk traders" who sold her for drinking
money.
"You have no place in this story.
You come from nothing.
You're nothing."
Knowing this makes one particular moment in
the Rise of Skywalker trailers all the more
intriguing.
During the final trailer, as they face off
in the rain on a piece of wreckage, Rey is
seen looking at Kylo Ren while her voiceover
states, "Nobody knows me."
The camera cuts, revealing Kylo Ren as he
activates his lightsaber and his voiceover
replies, "But I do."
Putting these two shots and their corresponding
voiceover one after the other in the final
trailer certainly implies Kylo Ren will reveal
Rey's past, or some other potentially earth-shattering
truth about her, that will change her direction
in The Rise of Skywalker.
It's the kind of tease that gives you deja
vu.
Haven't we already dealt with this issue?
Was Kylo lying before, or are the trailers
lying now?
Furthermore, does anyone even care who Rey's
family is at this point?
It wasn't Luke, it wasn't Leia, and it wasn't
Han, and it's probably not Lando.
This late in the game, would a big reveal
about her parentage even matter?
It's probably Palpatine, isn't it.
Maybe that's how we get evil Rey.
Why not?
"This is where the fun begins."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.